in die faser therme hatte sich
regelrecht verbot der franzose le carré
28 jährige kürzlich in rom in der
normandie das lokale architektur museum
widmet ihm eine sonderausstellung und
ehrt somit seine grafische verarbeitung
des architektonischen meisterwerks in
den fernen schweizer bergen ich bin
heute extrem mit diesem ort verbunden
einerseits ist da die ästhetische
faszination und dann weil es der
schauplatz meines ersten comic buches
ist der magnet hat beim französischen
publikum seit erscheinen vor einem jahr
einen nerv getroffen
20.000 verkaufte exemplare für seinen
verlag der bestverkaufte titel des
vergangenen jahres bisher übersetzt auf
deutsch und italienisch englisch ist
geplant
wir sind sehr glücklich heute abend
lücke an den autor hier zu begrüßen mit
seinem verleger comics zeigen wir hier
nicht zum ersten mal
wir schauen die architektur gern von
anderen seiten her
für mich ist das toll für einmal weg von
den spezialisierten comics galerien dem
verkauf von original
das gibt der geschichte eine andere
bedeutung und zieht leute an die sich
nicht so für comics interessieren
sondern mehr für architektur
zeigt auch wo man dieses medium
architektur noch hinführen kann wo sich
die beiden gebiete über nachricht
lucarelli lebt in der pariser peripherie
[Musik]
der vater hat ägyptische wurzeln die
mutter polnische beide sind architekten
[Musik]
wie vorgezeichnet war so sein weg ins
architekturstudium schon nach einem
halben jahr brach er aber ab
die kunsthochschule war dann mehr sein
ding
doch die architektur begleitete ihn bis
zur abschlussarbeit
ich habe mich für eine rückkehr zu
meiner früheren liebe entschieden
ein langer comic mit einer richtigen
geschichte da hatte ich all diese comics
im kopf die ich seit meiner jugend liebe
die so genannte linie klären
der klare strich an die zeichner die
mich begleitet haben dass sie billig wie
von alleine auf die therme gekommen dass
mit 13 besucht habe mit meinen eltern
die architekten das war wie
offensichtlich unglaublich dass dieses
gebäude nie als schauplatz gedient hat
für einen film oder einen roman oder
comic ich musste natürlich gut
recherchieren da ich nicht mehr an den
ort zurück konnte als student hatte ich
wenig geld und sehr wenig zeit bin ich
im internet auf ein 3 d modell gestoßen
so konnte ich mich überall umschauen
hatte viele ansichten und perspektiven
das hat mir viel gebracht und welche
rolle spielt der thermen schöpfer zum
tor
wie sieht er ihn ich habe mir lange zeit
gar kein bild von zum tor gemacht der
name war für mich mit diesem gebäude
verschmolzen und eine abstraktion wie
bei vielen künstlern und autoren die man
mit einem einzigen großen werk verbindet
daheim in paris verkörpert ein kleines
erinnerungsstück den bezug zum großen
werk ging mit meinem vater in vaals
spazieren da war dieses losenstein stück
an der seite des gehwegs ich habe es als
erinnerung aufbewahrt von einem einzigen
besuch